how's it going bread my name is beautifu
and welcome to scary Wow why do I feel
so short welcome to everlasting life
what is that noise oh I don't like it
[Music]
hello hikone in here I ran from the
water thing I think no I had a [ __ ]
what's a bra Oh
dork what who said that
piggies are you who's watching my ass
what we got in here this looks
suspicious
god damn you go in the closet get in the
closet bra ah what what do I have here
lover I pull it I don't have any oil god
damn it let me just hello what was the
point of that
Oh JA double pass on it needs gears it's
gears needs to be greased that's like my
painting that's gay Haley you're gay
okay I'm gay I'm sorry no I'm not okay
we had to hide David because semen
wanted him to die bloody semen semen is
a powerful thing the man or something
semen was not visible to our eyes but
many people didn't listen to him and
they eventually died in their sleep with
semen all over them ma that doesn't help
us we need alright let's find some edge
find some bloody oil shop door
ah
shh-shh
it's [ __ ] ambience shut me it's the
shell what is going on here this place
is huge
what hello okay
hey Martha all right that's fine
oh I don't like this no sir what is that
what is this a map it is a map that's
really weird all right so I guess I'm
there but it doesn't tell me where
anything is
I'll [ __ ] it let's go here I'm sure I
bet sure they all I'll find my way whoa
everyone need to show loose no not this
sound I hate that sound
don't sharp your knife another map what
are we doing down here
all right fine I'll keep going straight
[Music]
it really likes big maps I'm not gonna
lie
I don't know why anyone rely on my date
right door hello Wow
what do we got in here a note it's was
really funny but sometimes during the
nighttime and cleaning out of rooms but
we never saw him before him we never saw
him should I tell my mommy and daddy you
should not tell your mommy and that whoa
well mr. shy what did you do he wanted
me I swear I prowl it all right I trust
whoa nice jump hey be careful fish I
would never kill anyone you know that
Barry I trust you mr. hua got a fire
J says Christ look at this what a mess
there's not even oil here come on
nothing what are you doing here dude I'm
scared all right it's like huh let's
said that it's really nothing in here
huh
well goddamn I thought there would be a
smooth episode but now I might actually
be editing in Bonn son of a [ __ ]
don't even think about see if we have a
map here yeah we're over there
how nice ah shut up [ __ ] me
why would you explode in my face that's
what she said
Oh No I'm sick of your [ __ ] you know
that I run around so much like an idiot
it's crazy where's the door here I even
run past it now I didn't see it I could
literally run around it for million a
year sub holy [ __ ] what are you doing
here are you trying to tell me something
you can whisper it to me I'm less than
1000 K alright cool
[ __ ] I am so out of everything let's
just open this far I don't even [ __ ]
know let's just go hey guys hi is again
nice and cozy ah let me warn my net boss
oh it's good god I feel so again all
right what do we got knee Oh
it's gotta be something and ah yes just
give me that [ __ ]
what oh okay
and now what blip blip all they want
thank you
random I always keep a big [ __ ] jar
of oil next in my bed
yep that's the solidus no now we need to
go and jerk that lever are you trying to
[ __ ] with me or something I'm not in the
mood alright oh stop what is this
I can't kill you hey what the hell is on
me
we're fine we're fine all right fine
we're fine
no I'm a problem I just get a shell hair
brace goddamn it
thank God that took so long just to find
that stupid oil well how did you come
back I'm [ __ ] you kidding me [ __ ]
this game all right it works now
brother's back I'm black I am black
anyway yeah I don't know why it didn't
work I was ready to [ __ ] kill myself
ah no not David David well I got his
butt alright David is dead I don't even
know who David is mr. Jack hey that's
right do it
did you kill himself after molesting me
don't worry about it I got this under
control why did you look for me I made
this note one of the last days everyone
was already dead and my family well I
drank the content of the amnesia bottle
I don't know why and I didn't even have
enough time to think because I was
starving to death in a terrible place
this place is already 150 years old I
don't know how I came in here but one
thing those bad things are just seeing
are just illusions not real but they can
hurt you for some reason all the
problems are leading four to one reason
see man
best villain ever he did all of this bad
things do the world a favor find him and
destroy him before the force is getting
released goodbye and thank you for your
own effort and help okay the lab team
well [ __ ] me that means we gotta find a
lab I know why I bought it with these
it's not gonna be anything all right
David I'll avenge you after you to cut
up but parodies dead that's disgusting
don't worry about it all right the lab
huh well that's fine I'll find your lab
II I'll find you and I'll eat you but
you can't eat a lab I didn't know that
that is near and afar forbids
understand oh it's probably mental no
it's not
or is it no I know where the lab is it's
that [ __ ] door that just won't a
[ __ ] open it's over here
I got it for us this place was [ __ ]
terrible I probably spent in total 30
minutes at least in this place it's
running around like a [ __ ] idiot yes
yes yeah I'm so happy
what is this let me take a little of you
alright
the tonic is completed according to
wares instructions are we even got
barrel oil we finally obtained the acid
but we have no continue to play today
actually I [ __ ] do okay
ah what a problem they've managed to fix
the [ __ ] potion but not a what do I
do with this I think I'm done in here I
don't think I'm done in here
hey hey yeah I'm done in here I'm out of
heat all right let's proceed to the
third part or whatever god damn it this
is really boring episode I'm sorry not
this again
ah the hell am i I gotta find the exit
why it's the exit if only I could find
the exit I would be really happy really
really happy I'll be back here again I
walk in circles at night
oh I think the exit is here actually
No
it's close to this point I know that I
think it's over yeah
found what ah no I don't take a wife I
guys hey hey hey calm down calm down
let me squeeze through now that's good
god damn you Larry
god damn you Larry brother all right you
want me to go over there don't you ha ha
ha [ __ ] all right I'm just gonna go over
down Wow
all right fine I'll go here see if I
care noobs freaking noob stairs fine I
go over Hey
see if I care
Joran just [ __ ] with me fine
what is it Larry see if I care
all right final gun here Wow Wow no one
misses check your scrap what don't say
that
all right what idiot out by the dead
cats barrels you murdering kids now now
cold mouth not cool not cool [ __ ]
barrels I get you for this god damn it
why do you want me to know now oh shut
up what
all right don't gotta go I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go home don't freaking good
not even what about a breast
don't even worry about it it's not even
behind me I got this I got you me
alright just [ __ ] music is freaking
me out - what a hell shut up Larry
[Applause]
you're going here that's fine it's by
the time it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's [ __ ] fine that's fine
hello oh thank god ah what am I supposed
to use with this think we lost him
wait am i suppose oh he's close oh it's
close no no why did I run oh no buena
multi Nevada Oh judge God oh is the poof
a it was a poof a it was perfect oh
thank heavens Larry you're supposed to
tell me where to go
Larry this is not the right directions
oh my god damn it the [ __ ] poo poo
poo firs man
I ate them for breakfast alright alright
alright I got it I got it
there's the exit jayson's Christ this
area was terrible
all right press this will probably be a
really long and uneventful episode I'm
sorry about it hopefully the next one is
better sight you'd not be a breath
way more than I ever imagined but hey
next week two million can we do it
camera no Adam maybe you bros always
seem to surprise me so let's see I'm
gonna show where I donate the money so
let's cut the pity pie in the future